[Music]
mandatory
in syria they were skilled tradesmen
with their own businesses
after fleeing to the uk these former
refugees are now on a course in bristol
as they rebuild their livelihoods there
are so many skills so many abilities and
lots of
people coming into this country who are
motivated
to
improve their lives which have been
tragically damaged and they improve
their lives by being productive let's
help them be productive
it's a taste of how afghan refugees will
be helped as operation warm welcome
begins
the newly appointed afghan resettlement
minister was also in the city to meet
with families who've just arrived from
kabul
today we have announced that people
who've arrived under the arap scheme
which is the scheme for
people who've helped us over the last 20
years that they will receive indefinite
leave to remain and that will mean they
have stability but it also means that
they're able to for example seek work
mohammed was an interpreter but fled
with his family in july and is now
starting his new life in bristol
if i don't get a job like that easy so i
need to take some courses like it
courses i applied for them maybe i can
take away next week and
i've done the schools for the schooling
uh for the for the kids
so they might go to school next week as
well i have done the same thing for my
wife she's going to take some english
classes
by the beginning of september bristol is
among just a third of english councils
which have agreed to take in refugees
the government insists they are in talks
with many more and they will be needed
in the last two weeks more than 15 000
people have been airlifted from
afghanistan by british armed forces that
includes eight and a half thousand
afghans who had worked with the british
and they'll be relocated across the uk
under a policy for former staff but
there's also a separate scheme for
afghan refugees and the uk government
has committed to resettling up to 20 000
of them in the coming years
as those in need arrive up and down the
uk volunteers are preparing the
government may get refugees here but it
will be charities and communities
helping them to make a new life and home
damn white is sky news in bristol